as we take a look at the Vatican this
morning a secret archive deep inside the
catholic church's headquarters catalogs
every word written by every pope over
more than a thousand years our Seth
Doane got a rare inside look and shows
us the massive effort to make the
documents more accessible
[Music]
deep inside vatican city lies a bunker
holding a remarkable historical record
millions of church documents including
decrees and correspondence from every
pope dating back more than a millennia
lined up it had stretched more than 50
miles about the length of the Panama
Canal
today only academics with special
permission can access this otherwise
it's locked away this is the Vatican
secret archives yes upstairs Marco
Moreno of paleography one who studies
ancient texts showed us the frescoed
room where the archives started 50 mile
valuable records including this papal
correspondence from the 13th century
have not been digitized and remain
inaccessible for most it has obscure
abbreviations and is hand written in
medieval Latin solitaire
where is the you the difficult also for
human and even more difficult for a
computer which needs to identify letters
to transcribe and make the text
searchable enter an unlikely group of
helpers hundreds of high schoolers in
Rome what looks like a rudimentary video
game is actually a lesson in Latin that
students including Christian Giannini
are teaching the computers the program
doesn't know which of these letters are
in a B so by highlighting them we can
teach the program this was your idea
yes it was my idea hello Mary Aldo a
professor at Roman
a university in Rome enlisted 600
Italian high school students to help
these computers develop this linguistic
artificial intelligence we are providing
a sort of Google Translate for
paleography
sort of Google Translate for ancient
texts yeah artificial intelligence can
democratize these documents allowing
them to be digitized and made accessible
beyond the Vatican walls the technology
could also one day be used to decipher
ancient manuscripts anywhere it's a
clash of two very different worlds yes
it's beautiful for us what a beautiful
because if successful so many more
people would be able to explore the
ancient writings that surround him I can
imagine that I stay inside a story it's
like traveling back it's a time travel
yes a journey that high school students
and new software are revealing inside
the Vatican secret archives for CBS this
morning
Seth Dome Vatican City I when I look at
those old documents and I see that
incredible calligraphy all I can think
of as the hours and hours it took to
write that what I love about that story
is that these correspondent these are
just letters back and forth and they
could be chatting about the weather you
know the best robes this season who
knows what that will make it accessible
you know what I think Seth Doane has a
greater sign so bad life not so bad